et on prend la direction de cour
cheverny dans le loir et cher là-bas
plus de 250 maisons se fissure à cause
des sécheresses à répétition dans le
département des dizaines de communes
bénéficient de l'arrêté de catastrophe
naturelle qui permet une prise en charge
des assurances mais pas cour cheverny
dans les habitants vous allez le voir
sont au bord de la crise de nerf laurent
clavel chez mireille le tour du
propriétaire c'est comme un dimanche
pluvieux divers déprimant et monotone
une litanie de fissurer de craquelures
qui lézardent les murs de sa maison
regardez là c'est drôle est apparu comme
ça ça veut dire quatre ans comme ça
comment ça a commencé et petite fille si
l'élan du pignon et puis l'année à la
naissance ya quatre ans entendre sa
maison craquer la voir se déformer en
cause un terrain argileux qui bouge en
permanence sous l'effet des sécheresses
et des pluies d'hiver
mireille dos maintenant forcés pour
fermer les volets les portes et les
preuves au quotidien là des fois le
moral il est pas fort
quand vous voyez on est là je vois l'été
arrive et je me dis des fois je les
mesures et en fin de saison fin d'été
jeudi matin enfin grâce à ses larges et
d'un centimètre et à cour cheverny
la retraitée loin d'être un cas isolé au
total plus de 250 maisons lézardées et
chaque année de nouveaux dossiers pour
nelly de ben avec le maire cette
habitante se bat pour que la commune
obtiennent la reconnaissance de l'état
de catastrophe naturelle
elle permettrait une prise en charge des
travaux par les assurances
sauf que depuis 2015 la commune est
systématiquement recalée
incompréhensible que les gens viennent
voir sur place que les responsables
viennent vivre avec nous ce que l'on vit
aujourd'hui on est complètement
abandonné on a fait des économies
pendant toute une vie de travail pour
obtenir au moins une maison et
aujourd'hui on n'a plus rien du tout
parce que nos maisons sont invendables
en loir et cher rien que l'an dernier 54
communes ont bénéficié de l'arrêter
notamment celle est limitrophe de cour
cheverny
ce qui interpelle le maire les
mouvements de terrain s'arrête deal aux
frontières administratives
sur quels critères météorologiques la
commission interministérielle se base
tels les multiples lettres au ministre
de l'intérieur n'ont pas permis
d'éclaircir ce mystère
on nous dit météo france on s'occupe
d'eux des résultats en demande les
résultats météo france à ma connaissance
j'ai pas de station météo france dans la
région qui peut certifier que cour
cheverny n'a pas eu de sécheresse ou n'a
pas donc on se bat contre un mur le mur
administratif le seul qui aujourd'hui
semble ne pas vouloir céder pour les
habitants
plus le temps passe plus les dégâts sont
importants le montant des travaux de
consolidation et de réparation pour
certaines maisons flirte aujourd'hui
avec les 100000 euros
[Musique]